bonjour et bienvenue sur France 24 sur
Radio France Internationale nous sommes
à Djerba en marge du 18e sommet de la
Francophonie notre invité le président
de la Commission de l'Union africaine
Moussa fakima merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous merci et avec moi pour cette
interview Laurent Corot de RFI bonjour
ou safaki
on va commencer avec la situation dans
l'Est de la RDC les combats se
poursuivent les pays d'Afrique de l'Est
sont en train de déployer une force
régionale les efforts diplomatiques se
multiplient alors une question simple
mais grave est-ce que vous pensez qu'une
solution diplomatique est encore
possible ou est-ce que vous craignez un
embrasement régional cette situation
n'est malheureusement pas nouvelle
depuis pratiquement plus de deux
décennies
l'est du Congo et on trouve c'est
éprouvant pour le peuple congolais c'est
éprouvant pour son voisinage c'est
souvent pour l'ensemble du continent
mais
dans ce genre de conflit
nécessairement il faut trouver une
solution politique
et donc le processus qui est engagé en
aérobie avec la Communauté Est Africaine
les efforts du Président de l'Angola qui
a été désigné par l'Union africaine
comme facilitateur je crois que ces
efforts combinés doivent nous amener à
trouver une solution politique en tout
cas c'est ce qu'on préfère alors
justement les autorités congolaises
refusent de discuter avec le M23 qu'elle
considère comme un groupe terroriste
est-ce que ça ne fragilise pas la
recherche d'une solution négociée
écoutez à écouter le
l'envoyé spécial de l'ancien président
du Kenya oukourou kenyata
les discussions de Nairobi doivent
continuer
c'est au congolais bien entendu
déterminer quelles sont ceux qui vont
prendre part mais il est souhaitable
dans le cadre de la recherche de la paix
qu'il soit le plus inclusif possible
c'est notre souhait mais de toute façon
ce sont les parties elles-mêmes qui
savent de quoi il s'agit je vais revenir
à la situation au Tchad les autorités
ont décidé de prolonger la transition
d'ouvrir la possibilité au chef de la
jante ma matrice débit d'être candidat
aux élections à venir il y a eu les
événements tragiques du 20 octobre ou
une manifestation a été réprimée dans le
sang
dans un rapport que vous avez remis au
Conseil pays sécurité de l'Union
africaine vous avez demandé la
suspension du chat en affirmant que
c'est nécessaire pour je vous cite
sauvegarder un minimum de crédibilité et
être cohérent avec les situations dans
d'autres pays à savoir le Mali le
Burkina Faso la Guinée et le Soudan ça
pose la question est-ce que la
crédibilité de l'Union africaine a été
mise à mal dans cette affaire je crois
qu'il est nécessaire de
situer les choses dans leur contexte
en avril 2021
le président de la République du Tchad
le maréchal Idriss Déby a trouvé la mort
de manière violente paix à son âme
et en ce moment
contrairement à la pratique de l'Union
africaine qui en cas de changement donc
constitutionnel suspend presque
automatiquement l'État
l'Union africaine notamment le conseil
peut être sécuritaire envoyer une
mission sur place pour pouvoir examiner
les circonstances particulières qui ont
conduit à la mort du président
et les Noirs africains donc à travers
son organe compétent que le CPS a décidé
de ne pas suspendre le chat mais au
contraire sa décision comporte
pratiquement les dispositions ou les
décisions qui sont généralement plus en
cas de changement non constitutionnel
notamment en insistant sur un délai de
18 mois mon renouvelable
et
l'inéligibilité des militaires qui sont
à la tête du Conseil militaire de
transition
18 mois après il y a eu le dialogue qui
a été organisé et donc ces deux
conditions qui sont la contrepartie de
l'attitude Clément de l'Union africaine
n'ont pas été respectées
et naturellement donc en tant que
président de la commission en charge de
mettre en oeuvre les décisions de ces
organes je présente un rapport que
certains ont trouvé Dakar blanc ou
réquisitoire mais moi je le trouve
plutôt exigeant
trouve exigeant et clair d'autant plus
que il y a manifestement
une violation et des décisions et des
principes et de l'engagement pris
par le président du Conseil militaire
des transitions et donc j'ai soumis ces
rapports au Conseil PS sécurité en plus
il y a eu ces événements que vous citez
qui marque pratiquement la fin de ces 18
mois qui ont été réprimés violemment et
naturellement tout ça je devrais le
porter à l'attention de l'organe qui est
en charge
le CPS à discuter de la question il a
pas encore vidé il a suspendu ses
travaux et je crois qu'il va les
reprendre avant la fin de ce mois pour
suivre c'est ça la donc est-ce que ce
n'est pas quand même un problème de
crédibilité de toutes les façons la
décision n'est pas encore prise il y a
un certain nombre d'États qui ont estimé
qu'il faut suspendre le chat à l'exemple
des autres pays d'autres ont estimé
qu'il ne faut pas le faire et puisque
c'est une décision de fond pour que la
décision soit prise dans un sens ou dans
un autre il faut recueillir les 2%. le
2/3 c'est la raison pour laquelle je
crois qu'ils ne sont pas arrivés à ça et
la science a été
reportée pour reprendre et donc quel que
soit les décisions nous avons la mettre
en oeuvre bien entendu alors justement
où ça fait qui m'a Amad comment est-ce
que vous expliquez que pour certains
pays comme le Mali la Guinée le Burkina
Faso l'Union africaine parvient à
rappeler les principes à les poser alors
que pour le Tchad elle a plus de
difficultés est-ce qu'il y a une
exception de tchadienne est-ce qu'il y a
eu des pressions à ce sujet sur le
conseil et sécurité je ne sais pas le
concepts composés de 15 États c'est aux
États membres de pouvoir discuter et de
prendre une décision mais manifestement
dans le cas il y a une violation parce
que un répit a été donné aux autorités
de la transition mais finalement elles
n'ont pas appliquer les décisions qui
ont été prises par le Conseil peut
sécurité c'est ça la réalité mais je
vous repose ma question pourquoi le
Conseil peut sécurité ne parvient-il pas
à se prononcer sur le Tchad alors qu'il
est arrivé sur d'autres pays ce sont des
états pris individuellement et qui
expriment leur point de vue sur la
question
vous avez mentionné évidemment les
événements du du 20 octobre les
autorités de tchadienne affirment que ce
n'était pas un mouvement de protestation
mais que c'était une insurrection qui
était planifiée est-ce que cet argument
vous convain de toutes les façons quelle
que soit les cas de figures
expliquer aujourd'hui officiellement
plus de 50 morts 300 blessés pour une
manifestation de civile me semble une
utilisation
abusive des armes et donc bien entendu
il y aura je l'espère des enquêtes
indépendantes mais le fait lui-même
d'une manifestation dans les villes et
qu'il y ait autant de victimes me semble
quelque chose d'extrêmement grave
le gouvernement tchadien vous accuse de
vouloir sanctionner le chat coûte que
coûte il affirme que vous faites tout
cela parce que vous souhaitez être
candidat à la présidentielle tchadienne
à la fin de la transition comment est-ce
que vous réagissez à ces accusations
cette question de candidature ou pas de
candidatures je suis un citoyen
et je crois que citoyens qui remplit les
conditions peut à un moment ou un autre
avoir des ambitions ou un projet pour
son pays je crois qu'il y a un amalgame
entretenu Siam
au départ on m'a accusé de pouvoir faire
la part belle à mon pays qui a échappé à
la suspension maintenant c'est le
contraire
donc je crois que c'est une querelle
politicienne sur laquelle on veut
m'entraîner en tout cas je ne tomberait
pas dans dans ce piège ce qui est
évident en tant que président de la
Commission de l'Union africaine je suis
assermenté et je dois vraiment situer
les choses dans l'air contexte j'ai
soumis un rapport et personne ne
conteste aujourd'hui que les conditions
qui ont été mises par le concept
sécurité ont été allègrement négligés
voire violet c'est là la réalité mais
vous venez de dire que tout citoyen de
Chadia qualifié peut être candidat donc
ça pose quand même la question est-ce
que vous excluez ou pas toute
candidature à la prochaine élection
présidentielle
il y a 18 ans et demi en 2004 votre
confrère boit vous vienne me poser la
question quand j'étais encore Premier
ministre si j'étais le dauphin du
président débit donc cette question pour
moi elle revient très souvent je ne si
je représente le je ne sais pas le
portrait robot de de ce fameux candidat
je ne pense pas que le problème soit à
ce niveau
mais vous n'exclez pas une candidature
quand même dans la journée je suis
président de la Commission de l'Union
africaine il me reste encore 2 ans et
plus pour remplir mon mandat moi je me
concentre sur le travail que je fais
actuellement mais d'un point de vue
personnel est-ce que quand même le fait
que vous n'ayez pas été suivi par le
conseil de pays de sécurité est-ce que
ça vous a affecté
personnellement est-ce que vous vous
dites à quoi bon continuer finalement
peut-être dois-je démissionner allez
faire autre chose parce que les choses
de la même façon qu'il s'agit du Tchad
ou que de tout autre État
le travail du Président de la Commission
et de mettre en œuvre de décision de ces
organes
ça c'est ma responsabilité j'ai prêté
serment ça peut être le tchat ça peut
être tout autre pays je crois que je
suis totalement et je l'ai dit si demain
le conseil peut sécurité décide de ne
pas suspendre le chat j'appliquerai
totalement les décisions de ce programme
et pas démissionner je n'ai pas je n'ai
pas démissionné pourquoi dois-je
démissionner
j'ai été élu par l'ensemble du continent
j'ai un mandat j'ai fait mon travail
pour parler du Mali maintenant
moussafaki mamat la France s'est retiré
de ce pays les Européens sont vont les
Ivoiriens également est-ce que vous êtes
inquiet de voir une situation dans
laquelle les forces armées maliennes les
femmes et le groupe Wagner serait seul
face au djihadiste les troupes dont vous
parlez notamment avec celle qui sont
dans la minusma sont venus dans le cadre
d'une mission des Nations Unies
c'est vrai la plupart des effectifs sont
des effectifs africains j'espère que
cette mission puisse continuer quand
bien même nous à l'Union africaine dans
le continent de façon générale nous
constatons que les missions de maintien
de la paix en tout cas n'ont pas montré
une efficacité dans un temps contexte
comme celui du Mali il s'agit de trouver
la paix avant de la avant de la
maintenir donc la question des mandats
etc et donc
j'espère que cette mission va continuer
de rester ce sont des accords entre les
autorités maliennes et les pays comme la
France naturellement c'est au malien de
décider concernant l'Éthiopie un accord
parrainé par l'Union africaine vient
donc d'être signée entre le gouvernement
éthiopien et les rebelles du Tigré il
prévoit le retrait de toutes les forces
étrangères de la région or l'armée
hérite réelle est toujours présente
est-ce que son comportement le
comportement de l'armée hérite reine ne
va pas être essentiel à la réussite de
cet accord écoutez c'est qui est positif
c'est qu'il est parti c'est soit assis
autour d'une table
c'était
à la fin du mois passé en Afrique du Sud
elles ont signé cet accord important sur
l'association des hostilités et toutes
les façons il y a des acteurs eux-mêmes
les partis savent de quoi il s'agit
notre souci est de les accompagner
puisque se sont engagés il faut bien que
ces forces à un certain moment quitte
parce que c'est convenu entre les
parties
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et merci
à tous de nous avoir suivis sur nos deux
chaînes RFI France 24
[Musique]